[Music]
escaped soldier news oh how do you
escape that's the question you could be
like [ __ ] a Punisher and [ __ ]
submitted by Mohamed Hamzeh it fans
since 2013 every time I hear like oh
I've been a fan since 2009 if I'm at a
restaurant or like if I'm anywhere and
they're like Joe I've been a fan since
chinito Gomez and pendejo Chino or like
I've been a fan since the uncles in 2009
and I was like let me do that extra
attention for being a great fan we did
the [ __ ] Star Search no I give I know
I give them special attention the
[ __ ] ones that are like Oh Jojo I'm
the biggest fan I'm like really cool
what's your favorite Channel I forgot
they could be really nervous they could
be but then sometimes they'll call me
Bart oh that one's different yeah yeah
and then they'll say hey Bart my sister
loves your videos can I take a picture
cuz it makes her jealous it's either my
sister or my brother or my [ __ ]
somebody's a North Korean defector is
now being treated for an enormous number
of parasites and other health issues
after escaping across the South Korean
waters I saw this video videos crazy he
smuggled parasites at the South Korea
yeah what kind of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
so you're telling me all those shots
that we get it's actually good for us
mm-hmm there's all those natural moms
right they don't want their [ __ ] kids
to get a shot sentence for the end to be
always parasites I don't believe in that
[ __ ] I believe in apple cider vinegar
and [ __ ] blue bean well what happened
away today I'm imitating geo you are
nailing it thank you nailed it apple
cider vinegar
what happened
the soldiers North Korean soldiers 24
year old being identified as his surname
Oh he ended up leaving hey get back
you got a welcome in cuz that's charming
mistakes all those that makes it human
it makes you know this one got away okay
okay so he drove a Jeep
what did they drive it so he drop a jeep
like vehicles so he [ __ ] ran off with
the vehicle yes isn't it scary though
driving into South Korea because they
think you're invading with a jeep he
ended up getting stuck in a ditch yards
away from the from the border hmm and so
he jumped out of the vehicle you began
running in the for North Korean border
guards began firing at him with pistols
and ak-47 look they were firing more
than 40 rounds at him he was hit at
least five times he survived their
horrible shots he clung on to his life
as he kept crawling south so and finally
there were three South Korean soldiers
that crawled to him because he ended up
it's not funny that your own team is
blasting at you and the enemies that I
have you have secrets so they found a
lying in a pile of leaves south of the
line against the side of a building so
then that's when three South Korean
soldiers crawled out dragged him to
safety and in a US Army Black Hawk
helicopter transported him to a hospital
about 50 miles away wow I feel like
North Koreans are all survivors because
I'm assuming that everyone that's alive
there they deserve to be because they do
it without medicine or they probably do
it on one grain of rice every day yeah
they're saying
well on flight two all done like that so
they're saying that while on flight the
US Army flight medics had to insert a
large needle into his chest to help
re-inflate a collapsed lung that's just
just like the [ __ ] you see in movies a
[ __ ] did they take a pen to pop his
chest up in a blood came out she ordered
us yeah yep well right when they do it
right yeah by the time he got to the
hospital they found out that he had lost
such a large volume of blood that they
didn't even have time to check his blood
type they just did whatever pump them 40
units of type O blood into him so which
is like three to four times the amount
of blood contained in the human bodies
oh it's supposed to be for me too
he had to have a breathing machine to
keep him alive he's had three surgeries
one of them was to repair his damaged
internal organ and to stop the
contamination caused by 10 inch long
parasitic worms found in his intestine
an inch long he's had it for a long time
and a lot of them because the doctors
were saying that they have never seen
that in person and these worms South
Korea hasn't seen these worms since the
70s Wow
so forth damn it was like this is a
science project or some throw that worms
the doctors like I had only seen this in
textbooks like back Thursday were the
worms though it's like a clear
indication of how severe the
humanitarian and health crisis is if the
soldiers got worms there yeah because
soldiers are higher yeah what about the
regular people
oh yeah but they found like raw corn
kernels in his stomach which really
tripped them out the doctors not because
they were like what like usually they
have soldiers have a higher ranking in
the food they should be able to eat a
lot yeah that was eating corn husk and
ship uncooked corn yeah on
so I'm gonna show you guys a video well
Rob corns actually pretty good I've had
it before yeah yeah I bit into it is
sweet you can eat raw pork you can't eat
the dry one not the dry popcorn corn
that's hard oh yeah you can have no
[ __ ] molars left let me show you guys
a clip of his escape this was a badass
though
yeah because those fools that were
robbing that one store and that one
store that we talked about they got
capped a couple times they died like a
bunch of [ __ ] with a regular pistol
to the eggie that I don't care with
worms and his system yeah and the
[ __ ] blood drain out of his body like
a [ __ ] Capri Sun in an elementary
school yeah that's strong willpower
there everyone in the Mexican [ __ ]
culture knows that if you eat a lot and
you're still skinny you [ __ ] have a
long grace Bumbry say oh sure she's
taking off and then here the four
soldiers realizing that he's escaping
how do they know he's escaping he can't
drive man [ __ ] the shooting they're
shooting bad clothes yeah [ __ ] I thought
they were shooting far away they're
shooting like right there yeah yeah I
hope he zigs a good thing is not they're
not well trained I know cuz they miss
someone that tells us 40 bullets and
only five shots that's what were they
drinking soju a [ __ ] what happened cuz
you know what's funny at first I thought
like oh [ __ ] this guy's dope cuz he
dropped me all the way in to shoot I
think he tripped you know yeah
apparently they were plate like North
Korea has replaced those solders
probably kill them and they've also
planted trees near that ditch where he
ended up and like just making it harder
yeah I wonder what type of stuff he's
gonna tell the doctor who's saying that
he's a really sweet really quiet guy you
know when they run away though they [ __ ]
with their family and everything to
hopefully he doesn't have a family I'll
be cool if he was like ah orphans well
that's not cool but then it'll be good
there's no ties there's no one what do
you think you ran you think he just like
heard of stories of food and he's just
so hungry cuz he has a [ __ ] tapeworm
and he's like
I'm always hungry that's the saddest day
I heard of my life dude why'd you run
away
I heard there's something called food
where you're at so you know that's one
of the main things that defectors say is
I didn't know that there was this much
food in the world
damn cuz I was like that's crazy imagine
living in a world where you have no
[ __ ] clue you'd like starvation as
normal so you don't you don't think
anything else right so the only fat
person in North Korea is Kim Jong and
then that's why he's a sexy beast Thank
You people I think he's buff probably
yeah yeah he's don't know don't even
know that means I mean there was an era
when chubby girls or like super thick
girls were hot because everyone was a
skinny peasant and in only Royals and
everybody they could eat food to look
that way so sad man
[Music]